hey folks my name is jake host and
producer of gamespots podcast
this clip you're about to watch comes
directly from this week's episode so if
you want to hear the full thing
just search gamespot after dark on the
podcast service of your choice
and as always if you enjoyed this video
make sure to like and subscribe because
all that really helps us out
anyway let's get to it but anyway
jean-luc
outriders how is it oh boy outriders um
yeah so that is technically out as of
the recording of this ah technically
my favorite kind of out
uh nevermind um
uh the i i admittedly haven't got
too deep in past what was available in
the demo because i actually restarted
because the character i i originally
played was a technomancer which is like
a long range
class and oh boy trying to play that
game single player long range is
a bad idea because a bunch of the
enemies just like
rushing yeah so i did that class too and
i'm
regretting it i'm gonna re-roll i i
rerolled to
the pyro manser and i'm having a lot
more fun they're more mid-ranged um
their whole thing is you basically like
want to
get fire damage on enemies and then as
you shoot or kill those enemies that
have fire damage it gives you health
back
so that is that's actually pretty cool
it's like this fun little
back and forth loop but there's just
something about that game that is just
it's not it's not clicking in the way i
feel like it it should
um in pretty much every aspect
i was going to say are you talking story
talking gameplay because it's
i'm talking yeah i'm talking everything
it's like a story
it i i so like i recently replayed
a little bit of bullet storm which is a
previous people can fly game and i love
bullet storm because bullet storm
like just does not give a single and
it's like it's story is complete
nonsense it knows it's nonsense it's not
trying to be
anything serious it's just trying to say
like absurd the most absurd thing
possible just to like
get a get a chuckle out of you and i
respected about that because it's
at the very it's not like brilliant
writing but at the very least it feels
like
they're just having fun with it this
game
is like trying to be serious
with it with its like tone but then
also the characters will like have these
like
pithy one-liners thrown in so like
neither of it really works
and the none of the jokes land i think
because of like the
pacing of the cut scenes is awkward like
there's all these awkward pauses
between characters as they're supposed
to be like delivering these jokes and
and
they all fall extremely flat for me i
was like man
uh none of this is is like hitting the
way it should
so i i like the premise of like the
world but like just
nothing about the execution is is like
really selling me on it
i was uh i played the demo
uh up until the kind of bit that it lets
you go loose and
the bit in the story that got me is like
obviously it's like a end of the world
thing
an outrider searching for a new planet
and you're with
a guy tanner who's dressed like the guy
from fallout 4 who tells you that
settlements
are in trouble yeah and he
is like tells you that oh you know kid
it doesn't matter you let me die you
don't owe me anything i got you
the seat on the on the flight out and i
got another one for my daughter who's
pregnant
and i was like he's gonna die and then
he dies in like the next five minutes
and this is the first
opening ten minutes of the game and it
just felt yeah and
it's like you can do the b movie
sci-fi plot but if you're gonna take it
that seriously it has to be good
like if you're if you're in on it like
bullet storm wars
you know you can kind of get away with
it a bit more but the the writing for me
is like there isn't cool things in it
that i like
like the um the woman
who you're with early on in the game and
then like is
the lead later on and she's all like
disheveled yeah and and like she was
like happy-go-lucky and now she's just
like this cold-hearted you know because
of the
30 years you've been asleep like i agree
like i like the
i like that the beats they're trying to
do but then just like nothing about
the individual scenes seem to like
i i opened up the inventory
and i saw the destiny like
and i just i just let out a sigh because
i just
it just what's really weird is at least
so far
it it's it's the most like un
live service game i've played and that
like everything about its structure is
extremely single-player you're just
going through these levels you
occasionally do a side mission and then
you just keep going and you're picking
up loot
even the story is like you know it
it's like you're the last outrider and
there's like so there's like no like
story conceit for why i'd be playing
with other people the way like destiny
kind of like tries to seed all that
stuff in so it's like
why why is this game a live service game
it's
if it's very bizarre is it a live
service game or is it just
it has the trappings of a live service
game well it
so every time you beat a mission they're
like oh you can replay this mission to
get more loot
uh and you'll get different rewards or
you can roll back and do this and
there's like
um i granted i'm very early so like i'm
curious like what other
stuff kind of pops in later game but it
it
seems to be wanting you to like hey you
can redo these and you can roll for
different loot
it's got this thing called um world tier
which is actually kind of interesting oh
world tier is cool yeah world's here is
cool where basically
it's like you pick your tier and your
tiers your difficulty
uh and and that's also associated with
how much
uh like loot drops you get for like
legendary drops and at any point
even in the mid mission you can adjust
the world tier
uh which i think is pretty cool so like
um
playing the game solo it's actually
pretty tough if you try and like
follow at the current highest world tier
so occasionally i've had to like
oh i need to like bring it down a little
bit um because this is clearly
meant for multiplayer uh but it like
just lets you do that and
and i think that's an interesting idea
you know what other game does that
what avengers oh except
not very well how does adventures do it
i don't even remember
you can like this there's like
difficulties that you can change
before you go into a mission but like 99
of the time each time you finish it
you'll get some garbage that you don't
care about
so it's almost never worth it you're
like i was like
i'm just not gonna do this yeah see i
like that at least outriders lets you do
it like whenever you want
so you can just like lower it and not
worry about it
i don't know i guess like it still feels
like a
first or a single player third person
shooter with
rpg trappings as opposed to a live
service game for me currently like
i wonder i'm starting to rethink what
the kind of
what is the line that you cross when
when it to become a live service game
and
it doesn't seem like they're doing
anything like oh regular events or you
need to
i know it is maybe maybe like i i don't
think i've played enough but maybe it's
part of like
that keep grinding because there's one
trillion weapons in here and you need to
get the best ones before
like no one's talking about raids for
outriders are they no one's talking
about like
that kind of dungeons or stuff like that
it's just like you play it and then
you're done
i agree which makes it weirder that like
they do seem to be
somewhat pitching it as like a live
service game or like that it has this
replayability because i
i'm with you where it's like oh i'll
beat the story and then i'm probably
good you know i i don't really see a
reason to like
keep going it's such a weird thing
because
i bet you the idea of a live service
game is what is likely to get
it's more likely to get a game green lit
and supported
monetarily from a publisher side but i
bet you if they market it
as like this is not alive they they
haven't made it clear that this is not
really a live service game
and i every time i tell someone that
they're like oh that i'm kind of
interested in that now then if it's just
like a
co-op shooter that i can be done with
like years or something like that
with some rpg trappings i'm into it yeah
they're just not making a big deal out
of the fact that it's not gonna
it's not a game that you have to
dedicate your rest of your life yeah
it's way more like a borderlands in that
sense yes it's really like what it
should be more
pitched as because i would i would say
yeah that's the more comparable
comparison i want to see how i feel
about it like playing
co-op because i also don't find the
combat
like the best uh partly because like
so it's like a third person shooter but
the game very much
doesn't want you to stay in cover like
like they want you to be running around
and using the powers but
on the difficulty uh like me playing
like even when i'm like bring it down to
like i guess normal difficulty
it's they're it's pretty demanding like
they're throwing so much at you where
it's like okay
either you have like a bunch of dudes
rushing you constantly and you're like
okay i need to like be like constantly
zipping around or you have like guys
with snipers like shooting you
like with pinpoint accuracy from like
hundreds of yards away
so i'm like am i supposed to be like
bunkering down in cover and playing it
like very strategically or am i supposed
to be like constantly
you know rolling around like
i haven't found like a good flow of like
gameplay where i feel like i'm like
i'm in tune with the game and like what
the game wants me how the game wants me
to play it like i ha
and i'm still super early there's a
whole skill tree of powers that
i haven't unlocked and the powers are
the most interesting part so i'm hoping
it
it eventually clicks but right now i'm
just like yeah this isn't like
the best combat it's just kind of okay
and
like i said the stories got some
interesting ideas but
i don't know nothing nothing it's not
doing one particular thing
good enough for me to feel like really
invested in it
from everything you guys have said so
far it sounds like almost every aspect
it's just like
in everything is in competition with
each other like it wants to be a cover
shooter but it's
telling you it's kind of not it wants to
tell a serious story but also there's
weird jokes
it wants to be a live service game but
it's kind of not that it's more of just
like a multiplayer
rpg like it just seems like they were
very
like just there just wasn't a super
clear um
direction but you know like i probably
won't actually i might play because it's
free on gameplay
but like if that wasn't a thing i
probably would have skipped this
entirely
i mean the thing though it's game pass
it's cross play
um as well so it is cross play
but communication still is
is something that you've got to consider
[Laughter]
i feel like i i feel like i need to
channel the
the energy of our recently departed not
dead
still live reviews editor to say that
um as interim reviews that uh i feel
like it's necessary to say like this is
everything we've said is based on early
impressions few hours of the game
like and obviously individual to each
person
um we having said that we got our we got
our hands on the game the same time it
went live
um we do have a review in in the works
um so uh keep an eye out on the site we
probably will be taking a little bit of
time to
finalize the review but there might be
something written and in terms of video
up before that
um to kind of like early early review
impressions but yeah where
all of this is basically early days
early hours of the game
and subject to change or subject not to
change so
yeah that's that's our initial thoughts
on that
that's that on that oh and the game
always makes you be online
and if my internet dropped out for half
a second it booted me out of the game
damn it i did that it wanted me when i
started playing it on
xbox to get like my debater done it was
like you need to sign into a square next
account i was like no i mean
no way you're not playing this game then
yeah oh wow okay
[Music]
[Music]
uh